all over the world from the middle east
to Southeast Asia people are killing and
dying force and weather dug up from pits
in the ground or suction from the bottom
of the sea sand is critical along with
cement is a key ingredient in concrete
so it's vital to just about every
serious construction project anywhere
development is running rampant so is
sand mining or illegal sand importation
from Afghanistan to Jamaica Saudi Arabia
not every operation is large-scale on
thames creek in india men free dive to
the bottom with buckets other workers on
boats all the sand up from the bottom so
much that the creek is tens of feet
deeper now soon the divers won't be able
to reach the riverbed and meanwhile
illegal mines continue to dig crush wash
and send sand all buyers the trucks
continue
you
Oh